O!Sapiens Expert: I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know.
Arina Mokrousova: А можно. Оглосить. Список пунктов, которые мы сегодня обсуждаем.
FANATIC Agency: Я пока?
O!Sapiens Expert: to hit.
O!Sapiens Expert: I don't understand what you're saying.
Arina Mokrousova: Да, да, да. Просто. Ну. Вспомнил?
FANATIC Agency: Бра?
O!Sapiens Expert: Uh-huh.
FANATIC Agency: Я. Се. Скажу?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. У, нас классическая это. Деньги я. Скажу. Че Там текущая ситуация?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: Вот потом, час. Загрузится?
FANATIC Agency: Диана. Обсудить условия?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: Вот Значит что, делаемся, стратегом?
FANATIC Agency: Ищем не то если ищем, то кого, когда, и как?
FANATIC Agency: А Лола Закончились Три месяца испытательного срока?
FANATIC Agency: Вот у меня записанные, которые?
Arina Mokrousova: Но я думаю, что мне надо, типа Диана Лолога Потом. Уж страстья если останется, на него время.
FANATIC Agency: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: Такая типа темпа?
O!Sapiens Expert: Yes, yes, I understand.
Arina Mokrousova: Что стратегия сталася не, як Тому что. Мы, можем если, что, это из антоном на ком нибудь Вантувань не обсудить?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, Вот, этот последний чем?
Arina Mokrousova: Лоутон Убожение, Сша У. Тебя?
FANATIC Agency: Так. А где антон В? Родина Связи был?
O!Sapiens Expert: Uderoga.
Arina Mokrousova: Да, Он, же кладоехал, но, он?
FANATIC Agency: В смысле, он, приехал утром уже он в, смысле, вчера, ночью еще, приехал в питер питер он в Двенадцать Был.
O!Sapiens Expert: Brie.
Arina Mokrousova: Пытаюсь зацепиться?
Arina Mokrousova: Секунду. Он. За вагон за. Цепером. Стал?
FANATIC Agency: А?
FANATIC Agency: Или за вай фай?
Arina Mokrousova: Зум с коллективного. Вай. Фая не. Работает Почему, то?
Arina Mokrousova: Интересно. Интересный Поворот?
O!Sapiens Expert: I don't have any Wi-Fi, so I don't have any Wi-Fi.
O!Sapiens Expert: What do you think about this?
O!Sapiens Expert: The files personally clicked with your own.
FANATIC Agency: Можем в толк перейти, если?
O!Sapiens Expert: Pleasure.
FANATIC Agency: Если пряму что, не зацепиться?
Arina Mokrousova: Там там не. Будет. Транскрибация?
O!Sapiens Expert: There.
FANATIC Agency: Ну. Я, запишу для. Влады?
O!Sapiens Expert: I don't know if it's true or not. I don't know if it's true.
Arina Mokrousova: Мне кажется они, влад, внедрели но, там это. Бесплатно несплатная. Версия Да это тоже. Кстати Может быть я. Думаю. Что, на платная. Версия. Они же. Там много всего сделали они Сделали и альтернативу, миру?
O!Sapiens Expert: Prosthetic.
O!Sapiens Expert: Oh.
Arina Mokrousova: У них есть какой то свой сервис от, этих, досах там и, так далее ну. Короче. Много, всего, вот, просто. Когда у тебя платная версия там тариф короче? Разом?
O!Sapiens Expert: Whoa.
O!Sapiens Expert: Duplot University, Chile. Yeah.
O!Sapiens Expert: Thank you.
Антон Аверьянов: Yes, sir.
FANATIC Agency: Привет?
Arina Mokrousova: Привет?
FANATIC Agency: У тебя получилось Ура?
Антон Аверьянов: That's my duplicate.
FANATIC Agency: Ничего. Страшного. Все норм?
FANATIC Agency: Так, мы, короче, тут кратко обсудили чего хотим. Обсудить. Сейчас быстрый Денежный. Чек инг. Потом про диану Про Условия. Выхода про лолу которая, закончились, три месяца и если, успеваем то про, новую, стратега?
Антон Аверьянов: So it still happens.
Антон Аверьянов: That's the same.
FANATIC Agency: Че, как какая, у нас вообще какие, мысли? Ну, И Если, есть, еще какие, то, у, вас?
FANATIC Agency: Вопросы, то, я думаю, сможем успеем. Обсудить?
FANATIC Agency: Так про деньги. Я сейчас быстро скажу а. Там Ситуация у, нас какая, мы. Сегодня выплатили авансы?
FANATIC Agency: Вот и у нас Там в этом. Месяце. Довольно много платежей. По фри лан потому, что мы фрилов подключаем И на азбуку на тонов войс?
FANATIC Agency: На т банке. У. Нас. Есть этот. Фрилансер на пионере Будет и так далее у. Нас сейчас вот. С тех приходов, которые будут нам нужно оплатить фриланс?
FANATIC Agency: И налоги. И пока у. Нас, ну, у, Нас, там триста тысяч час для этого не. Хватает. Вот нуждем. Какие то приходы, либо от фьючерпрув либо От, То, до тела либо от, пионера?
FANATIC Agency: Вот Пока больше ничего нет.
FANATIC Agency: Вот соответственно. Следующие у. Нас планы по платежам это.
Антон Аверьянов: Let's see.
FANATIC Agency: Уже начало сентября. Вот это, т. Банк. Там. Восемьсот тысяч ну и, на ип вот должны прийти. Двадцать пятого числа?
FANATIC Agency: От Айбиэс. Деньги которые мы половину, Будем этим Эджа расплатить с учетом налогов. Мы сейчас. Вот с ними разбираемся как, нам это все. Сделать?
FANATIC Agency: Этих денег нам. С горем пополам. Должно хватить на. Вот выплаты диани и, на, какую то часть выплат зарплат и то, скорее всего, не всю, Короче Ну, Вот, будем понимать ближе к концу?
FANATIC Agency: Августок Началу. Сентября?
FANATIC Agency: Вот. Вот вот так.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mm-hmm, for sure.
FANATIC Agency: Вот ну. То, есть не сказать что то, мы сейчас, встряним в какой, то кассовый разрыв но есть вероятность как Я уже писала Что, да, мы в него попадем в задержку потому, что мы и не рассчитывали на вот отель.
FANATIC Agency: Выплаты. Диани. Два триста, кан?
FANATIC Agency: О, так, ну, Можем, плавно, к. Не. Переходить вам удалось. Почитать вот эти два варианты которые я, вчера отправляла?
Антон Аверьянов: No.
Антон Аверьянов: That's.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mmhm.
FANATIC Agency: Ну, смотрите, Да, если. Еще, раз если еще раскратка, это?
Антон Аверьянов: Oops.
FANATIC Agency: В отпуск, и чуть позже в октябре ей оплачивать вот, эти три оклада вот либо сразу. После. Четырнадцатого?
O!Sapiens Expert: No, no, no. No conceptual. No conceptual. No conceptual. No conceptual. No conceptual. No conceptual. No conceptual.
FANATIC Agency: А она же не будет работать в обоих вариантах. Ну. Типа, она, просто пойдет в отпуск друг за дружкой вот Она сейчас уйдет тридцать первого с тридцать первого там до четырнадцатого четырнадцатого уйдет снова до девятого октября?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ah, no, okay, what's going on?
FANATIC Agency: Вот либо вариант что, она как, бы четырнадцатого возвращается и сразу, уходит потому что, по, факту, арин если я, Правильно, помню и Понимаю. Если нужно, сдать в портал?
Антон Аверьянов: The…
FANATIC Agency: До конца августа. Вот надо. На Это интенсивно сейчас давить, потому, что вкус вел вряд. Ли. Вернется. До конца августа вот и?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. Хотелось Бы чтобы, она презентацию сделала по вкус вела а так Если Честно. Я. Не. Рассчитываю что, мыть что будет делать, но вкусвели у меня нет ощущания, что?
FANATIC Agency: Ага?
Arina Mokrousova: Она прямо нам нужна в. Сентябре в. Октябре. По большому Счету во Всех этих встречах она была бесполезность?
FANATIC Agency: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: И этот такаву, мы сдаем в понедельник. Дальше. Дальше, там у нас будет, какой то, синг?
O!Sapiens Expert: Hmm. Okay.
FANATIC Agency: Команды маркетинга в сентябре ну как. Бы, тут она нам тоже, не нужна, мы справимся?
Антон Аверьянов: Since I should have submitted this to someone else.
Arina Mokrousova: Ну воркшоп, кто то, да там не знаю договоримся там, вообще. Будет он. Или. Нет, но, кто, то, провелит?
FANATIC Agency: Да, не там не будет. Даже воркшопа?
FANATIC Agency: Уже договорились, что, да, это не воркшоп. Или Это просто созвон?
Arina Mokrousova: Монар?
FANATIC Agency: Поэтому?
FANATIC Agency: Вот так?
Arina Mokrousova: Нам. По большому счету, получается бесстрадница. Да, простила Вопрос только в том какого, числа у него будет стоять дата увольнения То есть, она просто будет официально дольше. Численница. У нас в штате и, все?
O!Sapiens Expert: Right.
FANATIC Agency: Ну. Нам, по деньгам. Выплаты вот. Это трехсот тысяч в. Октябре.
Arina Mokrousova: Ай, под деньги.
FANATIC Agency: Как, будто бы нам это чуть более безболезненно.
FANATIC Agency: Кажется, кажется, так, потому, что, я, сейчас если ей выплачивать четырнадцатого сентября?
Антон Аверьянов: Absolutely.
FANATIC Agency: Ну, мы, ей, выплатим вот с. Тех приходов которые будут, ст банка который придет, дану мыс. Высокой Доли. Вероятности скорее всего вот.
FANATIC Agency: Задержим, какую то из выплат?
FANATIC Agency: Либо пятого у нас будут задержки либо двадцатого пока, не очень понятно. Из за, то, что мы, пока не понимаем, В какой срок продукция прихода?
O!Sapiens Expert: Женя, Скажи, Анекдота, Гавриловна, Тебе Ничего не, говорила, На. Счет Того что мы дяне много будем выплачивать, процент на протяжении восьми месяцев это как?
O!Sapiens Expert: Норм?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. Так, проценты, это. Же у. Нас не официальная часть и, мы ее будем их выплачивать на самозанятую то есть, мы будем ей их выплачивать с ип.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
O!Sapiens Expert: А, К?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну. Нам, концептуальный вариант один. Предпочительный?
Антон Аверьянов: Hello.
FANATIC Agency: Какой, а первый в? Смысле?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Антон Аверьянов: Done.
FANATIC Agency: Это в отпуск ее отправить. Чтобы, она погуляла и мы, чуть чуть отсрочили платеж?
O!Sapiens Expert: Первый?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. Здесь чисто. Здесь. Неверно, как. Подать Ей эту историю то есть? Мы? Можем, сказать где надо отгулять, отпуск, отгуляй пожалуйста напиши Вот сейчас. Сразу же?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, Ты, Ж, Номинально, все?
O!Sapiens Expert: Just let me know now, I'm sure.
FANATIC Agency: Да, Ну, то, есть она, может сказать а я, не хочу отгуливать как бы. Я?
O!Sapiens Expert: Факт?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. Либо, у, нее есть дата выхода. В. Другую Компанию например ей нужно. Быть. Уже умолен место чтобы быть другу, другом?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вроде, нет?
FANATIC Agency: Я тоже сомневаюсь. Скорее всего?
O!Sapiens Expert: Пока?
O!Sapiens Expert: Сейчас просьба. Так, А мне уже есть отпуск. Да вроде.
FANATIC Agency: Тридцать. Первая. Да, да. Да. Да, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Августа?
FANATIC Agency: Да?
Антон Аверьянов: La Virginia Niger.
O!Sapiens Expert: Ты?
FANATIC Agency: Да, с тридцать первого по четырнадцатое найдет?
Arina Mokrousova: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тысяч. Концептуальна в. Первом. Варианте Тридцать Первое Ее последний день?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Arina Mokrousova: В команде?
FANATIC Agency: Не?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, Да Ну, что, отпуск, это, как бы, все?
Arina Mokrousova: Команди?
FANATIC Agency: Тридцать. Первое. Августа да. Да, да, да, да, да, да, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Arina Mokrousova: Но Он и последний день дожил во. Втором варианте если, Она четырнадцатого сентября из отпуска не возвращаются а сразу, прыгать следующий. Отпуск который, то, есть у него по факту все. Одно Схему?
O!Sapiens Expert: М?
O!Sapiens Expert: Няндамке?
Arina Mokrousova: Типа. Отпуск. По следующему вольнению?
Arina Mokrousova: Вопрос. Только?
Arina Mokrousova: Она отгуливает полностью. Весь отпуск и, тогда мы отсрочим оплату до октября либо она Отгуливает Только. Какую то частью, отпуска а оставшуюся не отгуливают, но получают за него компенсацию. Тогда мы, четырнадцатого должны ее, рассчитывать?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, Так?
Arina Mokrousova: Недели, после четырнадцатое?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Антон Аверьянов: Надо проборить на первый насколько, понимаю, вы, договариваться пробувати обчужать варианты?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но это декомунициру?
Arina Mokrousova: Антона У Вас. Не встречаешь от ты в. Пятницу да она, Поставила, так. И, тебе?
Антон Аверьянов: Педаг?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да. Встреча. Она просто хочет поговорить?
Антон Аверьянов: Надо. Сказав?
Arina Mokrousova: У меня просто с ней в пятницу тоже в антипа она то Его, так поставила немножко нахлест я не понимаю. Покочу его, отменять?
Arina Mokrousova: Или двигайте. Вообще если смысл мне если там, про что то разговаривают.
Антон Аверьянов: Ты. Можешь я. Скорее, всего чуки подвигнув встреча. Смирно часов, по восемнадцать?
Антон Аверьянов: Мне там. Сейчас, ну. Другая, очень, принесется то. Что, помолкает паралельно.
O!Sapiens Expert: Чисто для контекста. Но Когда я, с ней созвонился вчера то там нее как, это в. Процессе промелькнуло пару фраз Мне Кажется они, конечно, были, больше номинальные ноти внее ну, одна, по, крайней, вере, номинальная, из разряда типа, мне там, не было коммуницировано что заранее Что там у меня? Как то?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вовлеченность упала, И что это, типа неожиданно, но?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мне Кажется это, было такое типа. Вот. Вы, меня тут вдруг поставили перед фактом и. Вот это все и. Отпрос проигнорировал?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, нет?
Антон Аверьянов: Даль?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, нет, это. Не так. У нас, был. Как минимум.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, не нет. Тут. Я сейчас дополню важные момент ну как бы. Типа, ей то об этом, никто, не говорил заранее. Из разряда у тебя хуевой увлеченности мы. Что, То не видим и, ну, короче из, разряда, типа вы мне заранее не намекнули что меня могут уволить, Если я чех то, не поменяю?
Антон Аверьянов: Я понял?
Arina Mokrousova: Говорили, говорили, вам, да говорили?
O!Sapiens Expert: А Говорили?
Антон Аверьянов: Говорили блад, Да. У, нас был?
O!Sapiens Expert: Прим текстом. Окей Все?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, мы, когда делали оценку компетенции, моей, родно на этом и задержались видно, спрашивали, разбирали, вот, почему она еще. Когда можно учить побольше в клиента. Ложиться. Приносит, две гипотезе на двух слайдах и учебного делать, чтобы, она, включалась, больше?
Антон Аверьянов: Она напрямую, сказала эту фразу что теперь хера Мне делось больше если, по этот забрели потезой будет и, все?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Антон Аверьянов: Пусть там было понятно, что говорил?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну Она наверно, не, так сформулирована то. Что, платне, за две гипотезы типа есть же. Две. Гипотезы, Зачем делать еще ну. Как, Бы давайте, вот, я, скажу, это, мы еще говорили про. Встречу. Мою и ее мне, если честно Встреч ней, типа не нужна?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Антон Аверьянов: На молдав такого?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот по большому счету У меня нет в утреннего запроса. Там, с не о чем то, разговаривать. Я у него Прошу?
Arina Mokrousova: Типа. Оставляем ули дропам если. У Нее есть какая, то повезка то, я готова поговорить вот когда. Я, пришла в ноябре. В фанатике я встречалась со всеми стратегами и, со всеми спецами там с лерой говорила и. Так далее?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: И уже в ноябре Диана сказала, что я выгорила. Вот, я не знаю. Хочу. Свечки делать я. Не Знаю хочу ли заниматься, трояги и так далее вот, Это уже. Был мы с антоном проекто говорили я Им Пришла И сказала, а, челове слухай у меня, происходит?
O!Sapiens Expert: М?
Arina Mokrousova: Чему у вас там. Вот один стратег устал на точки там катя из. Последних. Сил. Работает А второй там в каком то, Экзистент Клинсе. Вот это как вот у меня это все написано, Что в Диана? Экзистентальный клинз. Это было видно в команде. Об этом мне сказала лера?
Arina Mokrousova: Что она типа особо работает, ты как бы и, не хочет вот. Дальше был хуевый воркшоп на вкусвилле который, как, бы ну тоже подготовка. К нему стало. Как, бы средствием этой низкой увлеченности но а дальше там. Снежный, ком сначала, у нее экзистенциальный кризис потом. Феврале задержки, зарплаты, и у нее понятна мотивация. Честь, финансовая Увлеченность, начала, падать, поэтому косить подурочку и говорить о, том, что она не, знала что, у нее падает в увлеченности это создает.
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Arina Mokrousova: Проблема на проектах. Типа не надо. Вот она. Прекрасно. Сама. Знала. С еще конца прошлого года что у Нее, Блетинзистенциальный, крис?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да ну. Я, говорю, от, номинально, больше как это?
O!Sapiens Expert: Такое типа знаешь, Переговорная? Позиция?
O!Sapiens Expert: Не прокатило?
Arina Mokrousova: Это не переговорное. Это желание жертвей прикинуться, что ей?
FANATIC Agency: Манипуляция?
Arina Mokrousova: Конечно, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это же через переговорного процесс. Ну. Второе, она, еще говорив что, вот там ей там?
Arina Mokrousova: Наверное?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что там? Про Справедливость? Начала говорить Диана. Ты. Получала Выш Рынка а. Как, до это в прошлом году гвинец Не только в прошлом году до. Этого?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, как то явно, с этим была не согласна но, я даже не стал копать туда и?
Антон Аверьянов: В чем?
Антон Аверьянов: Об чем несправедливость.
O!Sapiens Expert: Дропну?
O!Sapiens Expert: А, Ты она там еще то, не помню там. Конкретно какой был контекст а, но, она там говорила что справедливо ожидает там выплаты, процентов. И что то, еще или она, что то сказала, что то, это было несправедливо Хочешь поговорить про справедливость?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но мы туда решили не копать но что сама, такого, лада лад давай не будем? Туда, Игорь, Ты, Сама, Подняла?
O!Sapiens Expert: Чу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну короче, От просто для, контекста а, так Наш разговор не был продолжительным усло?
Arina Mokrousova: Все, что могли то сделать?
Arina Mokrousova: Учитывая ее низкую в увлеченность зная о, том, что, ей трудно работать, ее, как могли поддерживать на азбуке?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот со всеми вопросами, которыми она приходила. Быть. Ей. Всегда помогали вот. Она ко мне недавно пришла бар манифест, И спрашивать, ей, целое, сообщение. Написала со ссылками там на сайт где все, манифест хранятся и так далее то есть. Коротше?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну слушай. Понятно, что, оно не будет счастлива естестна кто будет. Счастлив в такой ситуации то надо, понять, человеческие эмоции, концептуальные. Все одно, правильное решение, для. Всех ей. Лучше Быть этого?
Arina Mokrousova: Это. Да, да, я зналась?
O!Sapiens Expert: Не будет болтаться какашка. В прорбе?
O!Sapiens Expert: Хоть это двинется, к чему то?
Arina Mokrousova: Короче, получается про деньги с ней разговаривает Влад в пятницу какое. То условное экзит, Интервью Назывем, Это Ильзы Интервью но. Это просто разговор делает антон И, я просто ей напишусь. Прошу типа, вам, туан оставляем или нет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, Антуан, С Не. Говоришь. Поговори с ней на, тему того как она, хочет, коммуницировать в команде чтобы это было, понятно, и без каких то странностей?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, Хорошо?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, Хорошо, Хорошо?
Антон Аверьянов: Хорошо?
Антон Аверьянов: Так, Давайте Следующий, таймер?
FANATIC Agency: Ну, Да, у, нас только единственное знаете получается что. Командная, Сходка, же в этом месяце ее тоже подвинули на четвертое по моему?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Антон Аверьянов: У тебя?
FANATIC Agency: Вот.
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Антон Аверьянов: И тамдеально не будет. Доктора?
FANATIC Agency: Да, да?
FANATIC Agency: Так. Я не помню, почему мы подвинули?
Антон Аверьянов: Легкоз?
Arina Mokrousova: Потому что там отпуска по моему, и день рождения еще алиса лола О Всякое Такое?
FANATIC Agency: А так, улоло, вроде бы двадцать Седьмого Ее не Будут д И оф А, Алиса. Тоже Не будут двадцать?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, да, да, да?
Arina Mokrousova: Не знаю надо, спросить, побеге режиме просто.
Arina Mokrousova: Ну? Я, помню что, то было, связано что, то с, какими то отпусками?
FANATIC Agency: О?
O!Sapiens Expert: И в один день?
FANATIC Agency: А это, скорее всего, да. Это. Скорее. Все было связан как раз с тем, что?
Arina Mokrousova: Нет?
FANATIC Agency: Диана, что Льв Отпуск, или, Че там, я не знаю не понимаю?
Arina Mokrousova: Она с тридцать Первого уходят?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну. И дни. Рождения. Внима.
FANATIC Agency: Да, нас. Тридцать, Первом отпуски а не, что нибудь может быть, нам, тогда оставить, двадцать восьмого встречу?
FANATIC Agency: Здравствуйте?
Arina Mokrousova: Можно попробовать?
Arina Mokrousova: Должен. Это допрос прездо успеть сделать но, Там какая то, была логика ученого четвертая?
FANATIC Agency: Там, там, Да, там, это Аня, не будет колягину но мне кажется не, критично может оставить. Просто, чтобы, я, не, знаю там где, аначет сказал может ее, предложить, Что, то сказать или, как, здеть же все таки?
Arina Mokrousova: Хоть. Я не знаю если, честно, кому она, что будут, говорить сейчас в кате?
Arina Mokrousova: Поверьте мне всем остальным?
Arina Mokrousova: Плюс минус?
Arina Mokrousova: Я ищу слово?
Антон Аверьянов: Понятно, что оно. Понятно, что она скажет?
Arina Mokrousova: Нет, я. Между всем остальным фиолетовым?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. Типа, даши, не, будет на сходке потому, что она сейчас по понятным, причинам но, Даже стб она была бы ей, без разниц алися без. Разницы лоли. Без. Разницы. Я с жени знаю Вы Знаете единственный Получатель этого сообщения, эта катя?
Arina Mokrousova: Это як тому, что на сходке, как бы?
Arina Mokrousova: На Викли, может рассказать?
FANATIC Agency: Ну Или Пусть, Ну, Давайте, тогда, С?
O!Sapiens Expert: Может письмо, отправить. Поезд?
FANATIC Agency: Когда ставим, четвертого как и, есть не будем, тогда ничего двигуть.
Arina Mokrousova: Есть вариант, что она расскажешь об этом. Сама Есть вариант. Шум, Этом Скажете, просто антон. На Каком. Нибудь. Виде?
FANATIC Agency: Я просто, очень, Да, очень, не хочу, чтобы опять все случился какой. То этот блять ну?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вопрос. Нам Все одно надо коммуницировать формально?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мискоммуникация?
FANATIC Agency: Да, да, вот это. Вот история.
O!Sapiens Expert: Давайте. Так, мы, ну, я. Сейчас, напишу дяне мы. С. Ней. Согласуем дату как только будет понятна дата я у него спрошу, как она хочет коммуницировать и дальше. Уже.
O!Sapiens Expert: Сразу. В общем, поле, решим?
Arina Mokrousova: Когда ты спрашиваешь а не, антон, как Она Хочет ко мне?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, Да, я спрошу сразу, что я все зависит. Илюмал. Суще. Датой.
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: Окей?
Arina Mokrousova: Надо Ли нам чтобы, на что то передавала какие, то дела презентации там я? Не знаю? То ее нужно сделать?
FANATIC Agency: Договорились?
Arina Mokrousova: Пайлость?
O!Sapiens Expert: Я думаю будет полезна, если она, ну ее попросить, выгрузить. Вообще. Все материалы на какую, то папку на сервере, который, у нее есть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Просто, чтобы?
O!Sapiens Expert: Осталось где, то, что то?
O!Sapiens Expert: Остальным проектам. Ну. Надо, Понять, да кому чего?
FANATIC Agency: А это о презентации в. Клауде. Они не хранятся это же. Общее вроде бы?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, Но мне могут быть, на ноутере?
O!Sapiens Expert: Какие то еще копии?
FANATIC Agency: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Или, может быть в ее ай клауде?
FANATIC Agency: Но. Ладно.
FANATIC Agency: Так. То, ну. Я, по своим проектам подумаю, там, мне, кажется, что, у, меня, нет, ничего такого, из?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. С Это, кажем хорошо?
FANATIC Agency: Все тогда по Диане?
O!Sapiens Expert: Гей, Дальше.
FANATIC Agency: Ладно Влад, и, ты, тогда скажешь че она, решит, потому что, если, она. Согласна, на, отпуск, то ей нужно будет сразу написать и заявление на отпуск. И в этот соглашение. Расторжение. Вот в котором мы пропишем эти триста тысяч и когда, Мы ей, их выплатим?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
FANATIC Agency: Так, так, так?
FANATIC Agency: Следующий. Вопрос у. Нас получается по лоле?
FANATIC Agency: Тут. Какая история. Мы. Здесь чехотели обсудить.
Arina Mokrousova: Мы хотели. Обсудить, что у него закончился. Испательный срок. В ее офере было написано что, когда, у нее исплатательный срок заканчивается, мы и предлагаем трудоустройство в штах?
Arina Mokrousova: От?
Arina Mokrousova: Час как будто. Бы нам не очень?
Arina Mokrousova: Не очень, как то, сказать его надо, отсрочно? Трудоустроиться штат потому, что, если мы ее возьмем то мы сразу, получим налоговые обязательства на нее же?
Arina Mokrousova: Найти. Памп?
Arina Mokrousova: Это еще дополнительная нагрузку финансовой которая, может привезти ктому что, мы ей, же Лучшем задерживают ее же зарплату типа пока, она самозанятая нам, або проще ей платить но При этом. У нас была договоренность что она, работает, самозанята в течении. Только трех месяцев сплять На высоке?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Arina Mokrousova: Это первое что, нам нужно обсудить то, Есть нам, надо понять какой то, разговор с ней коммуницировать я не знаю сколько, еще, насколько еще продливается этот срок на три месяца еще, до конца года?
Arina Mokrousova: Это Первое и, второе просто. Ну. У. Него. Закончился искательный срок.
Arina Mokrousova: Ну Я, Думаю что, мы не будем прошла она. Не прошла для меня однозначно прошла но, нам нужно?
Arina Mokrousova: Запустить какие, то?
Arina Mokrousova: Формальные процедуры. Вот?
Arina Mokrousova: Мы с не встречались на каждый месяц, для того, чтобы собирать фидбэк, Но и вообще как, то, синковаться че происходит, Вот она. Подготовит презентацию Вот. О Том?
Arina Mokrousova: В чем сделал за эти три месяца чем, она гордится что, ей, нравилось, и что ее мотивировало, что ей не Нравится и, что ее демотивировало вот?
Arina Mokrousova: Мне надо с ней встретиться во первом чтобы она, про это рассказала во вторг просто. Антон. Тоже у меня Антон для тебя. Есть вопросы? Их? Буквально? Пять Вот хотелось. Чтоб Ты Ну типа. Свое, который записал, мнение, обменяться короче эти мнение вот.
Антон Аверьянов: Ты? Сможешь как. Прислать?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, конечно, мне готова все. Вот. Мы короче, мы, должны как, то закрыть вот восстательный срок Вот. И кроме, того. С ней в целом поговорить. О том какие, планы, там, до конца года и так далее, то что. Мы Пока не, проводим ей перформанс, ревью не какое?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, класс. Хорошо, да. Давай?
Arina Mokrousova: Все одно надо с ней поговорить че она Хочет. Сделать в Профессиональном плане до конца года там какие ресурсы. Ей. Нужны вот. И все такое прочье какой, то, там тоже в, какую сторону она хочет двигаться с точки. Зрения там карьерного трека Пока без. Оценки. Компетенции без?
Arina Mokrousova: Треки, как для девчоных не собирали просто кобя в целом Вот?
Arina Mokrousova: А еще хотела ради и интересно запустить вопрос. Я на себя запускала в севраля Помните Мы сами даже обсуждали?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
Антон Аверьянов: Что то, типа оценки на триста шестьдесят от коллег?
Arina Mokrousova: Тоже. Коротенький Нач?
Arina Mokrousova: Нет, нет, не по компетенциям, триста, шагно, же по компетенциям а, просто типа Вот. С, теми кто, с ней пересекался Вот и просто типа. Вспомнить. Не Знаю Че больше, все, запомнилось. Застать. Мне срок?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да?
Arina Mokrousova: Что было классного, где были дискомфортные моменты? Не Знаю совет Ей на следующий квартал если она там?
Arina Mokrousova: Услуга, чтобы там эффективно работать. Фанальсики. Не знаю. Там.
Arina Mokrousova: В свободной форме. Ну. Как обычно запускают просто Какой То Вайб Чек это скорее знаешь мне. Оценка триста, Шестьдесят компетенция, А про степа вайб чек и, Допрос, Людей которые с ней там гдет пересеклись вот, а с, ней. Пересеклась. Даша. Алиса юля. Маркетолог. Наш, ну с ней достаточно?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да?
Arina Mokrousova: Много пересекалось вот лера Наводи Вот. Они там тоже покасатели.
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
Антон Аверьянов: Окей. Давайте?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну То, есть я, поставлю встречу я. Сначала тебя пришлю список. Вопросов и, с ней мы уже Поговорили что Ей нужно презентацию сделать я. Поставлю встречу мы. Там встретимся я. Не Знаю в каком формате.
Антон Аверьянов: Договор?
Arina Mokrousova: Надо, где туда идти или нет вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Надо тебя включать в эту оценку, или не надо хороше. Много. Еще нерви поговорим. Потом?
FANATIC Agency: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: Тут все понятно. А вот по первому вопросу штатный Штат Цим Занятим занято давайте обсудим Какая. У нас позиция, то есть Мы с жени уже предварительно, как бы обсудили, что нам именно сейчас мы в такой ситуации, оказываемся, что, у нас укате новый трек и надо скать и говорить другое то, же терной?
Arina Mokrousova: Финансовые финансовые вознахрождения. У нас уход Диана, мы и должны выплатить все. Вот эти отступные, Так?
Arina Mokrousova: Выбрал своемую с золотым парашутом, в его будущей, счастливой. Жизнь и, но если мы возьмем лолу Еще и прям сейчас Ее оформить штат вот прям условный там. Девятнадцатого августа тот создает. Для нас непомерно большую финансовую грузку вот все вод Эти?
Arina Mokrousova: Три одновременно, происходящих процесса с трена старшими структями?
Arina Mokrousova: Но при этом все одно тоже быть такими скольскими типами. И говорят аха мы. Передумали и теперь, мы необще не будем тебя никогда устраивать. Читать Это типа. Странно?
FANATIC Agency: Надо честно с ней поговорить и попробовать но как. Бы объяснить ситуацию там по диане она как вы, знает, что, она уходит. Ну. Сказать. Что вот, такая, ситуация и можно, там давай договоримся. Там. Не знаю. На отсрочку еще сейчас. В. Три Месяца?
O!Sapiens Expert: М?
FANATIC Agency: Вот для. Того, чтобы вот мы смогли сейчас. Вот эти с Дианы. Как бы все это выплатить. Вот Чуть Чуть поднабрать, подкопить. Ну. То, есть мне, кажется ты, должен быть, разговор такой что даже если, у, нас, не получается что то через десять, три месяца?
FANATIC Agency: Ну?
FANATIC Agency: Хд?
FANATIC Agency: Типа, Потом опять разговаривать давай. Еще отстрочим?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, Это, странно да, Надо. Понять. С, Какого, тогда какой срок, только небо знаешь?
FANATIC Agency: Три, месяца сейчас. Все получается сентябрь?
FANATIC Agency: Октябрь Ноябрь?
Arina Mokrousova: С декабря. Тогда надо будет то ее устраивать условность что, Там с первого декабря?
FANATIC Agency: Да, нули бы сразу поговорить что, типа, Дай, нам время пожалуйста, до, конца, года потому, что, сейчас, начинаются тендеры и все такое, Есть Шанс что, мы?
FANATIC Agency: Танин. Хотя. Бы на колени перед. Этим Кутом Катастрофом?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну. Давайте. Можем, быть так на прямой и поговорим?
Антон Аверьянов: Что все же видят, слышать все у меня люди сообще понимают?
Антон Аверьянов: Подскажи бы, что мной?
Антон Аверьянов: Будет. Большая. Налоговая нагрузка, можно предложить, Как по компенсировать приключения устройстве Чем там?
Антон Аверьянов: Чтоб она не чувствую себя в зеленом. Я Не знаю насколько, она думает о всех пенсионных общественных, и прочих по. Мещах?
Антон Аверьянов: Предложил, какой то срок?
FANATIC Agency: Но мы. Сейчас, если, какой, то компенсирование предложим как бы нас, ну как, бы это?
FANATIC Agency: Для нас это опять доб какая то финансовая, нагрузка?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну Давайте, Поговорим, просто какие, скажем что, по прогнозу декабрь?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ом?
Антон Аверьянов: Ари, Как Ты думаешь насколько, для нее критично это будет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Чало? Скажешь?
Антон Аверьянов: Ты. С ним, больше общаешься в землетством чтобы с ней говорила?
Arina Mokrousova: Я не думаю что это критично я, просто, думаю что, это имеет большой имиджевый эффект вот еще я. Говорю. Да с точки зрения, обещания. И я же с ней говорю мышь каждый. Месяц. Встречались вот она. Навстречу, брет. Она расскажет Что ей, не, нравилось. Что, ее, демотивировало?
O!Sapiens Expert: Стычки, за обещания?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, страшно?
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Демотивировал ее корпоративную культуру и отношения в команде?
Arina Mokrousova: От, и?
O!Sapiens Expert: Оу?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. Да, потому, что, она привыкла к другому но, мы про это все говорили жени говорила. Я. Говорила Вот Илон говорил, это, закономерно?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Просто. Я думаю. Да. Ну.
Arina Mokrousova: Она не чувствует такой включенности, как в команду, которую нам привет почувствовать. И вот для нее. Это больше. Имиджевый. Эффект. Что там. Есть люди, которые условно были устроены?
Arina Mokrousova: Они при этом меньше ценности приносили бизнесу она. Недурочка, она, это. Прекрасно Понимает Видит как, проекты, ведутся?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ясно. Также. Видишь что, с этими людьми прощаются?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, это понятно?
Arina Mokrousova: Мг?
Arina Mokrousova: Типа. У Них было официальное до устройстве?
Arina Mokrousova: Лос?
Arina Mokrousova: Нуной будь, Так, ибо оставаться?
Arina Mokrousova: Мы в целом работали в такой системе. В сигнал?
Arina Mokrousova: Например?
Arina Mokrousova: Я точно так же работал, как самым заняты потом кафе а, Лоу Была. В Штате то есть, песо в штате час. Выведино за штатом в этой Смс. Схеме. Нет Ничего такого сверхъестественного и, как, раз все новые спецы которые, приходили?
Arina Mokrousova: Они у тебя были. В Штаб, И Он?
Arina Mokrousova: Просто. Мы Ей Коммуницировали берем вот. А. Сейчас, Типа. Статус. Меняется?
Arina Mokrousova: Важно, чтобы, имеджево Для нее это. Не было сообщением что как, бы ее тут?
Arina Mokrousova: Мне трудоустраивать, потому что?
Arina Mokrousova: У некой, то другой?
Arina Mokrousova: Не знаю статус?
Arina Mokrousova: Типа, менее?
Arina Mokrousova: Важного. Не. Знаю. Мене Ценного члена команды, на которого типа, особо не рассчитываем?
Антон Аверьянов: Где она уходит?
Антон Аверьянов: Давайте. Может быть все таки, ну там понятно что часть фото. И Налоговой нагрузки с дианой уйдет.
Антон Аверьянов: У лола да. Будет, официально больше. Оклад.
Антон Аверьянов: Но может, мы, опять, же чтобы, эпиляционно не проигрывать не, переигрывать свои же решения здесь. Сделаем уровсу меня. Все. Таки может быть просто стоять проговорю. Что давай мы. Это, сделаем Родном момент когда выйдет, диана?
Антон Аверьянов: Я думаю, что лоли можно. Объяснить эту улогику что, ну не? Выйдет диана просто Чтобы у, нас не было месяцев когда обнаплате?
Антон Аверьянов: Сделаной. Закрываем?
Антон Аверьянов: Сентябрь, октябрь, как. Договорим все? В сентября мы? Официально для устраин был.
O!Sapiens Expert: Проблема. Смсо. Можем Гореть и попасть в разрыв и, не выплатить ей поэтому я. Кажу, я, все же прочь сказать что, давай, мы это возьмем с уже небольшую паузу до Декабря, потому что нам так проще. Тебе Гарантировать выплаты своевременно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Нежели, Но но с пониманием того, что все же, с декабря Мы тебя трудостроим.
FANATIC Agency: Если у нас придут, какие То Ну Тендеры, Не, знаю, там если, там т, банк, мы, выиграем там. Этот, полюс какой нибудь если, кто, то, там из Текущих еще тендеров?
FANATIC Agency: Заключится, то можно, ее оформить чуть раньше после того. Как мы Выплатим диане?
FANATIC Agency: Вот если мы понимаем, что финансовая ситуация в?
FANATIC Agency: Чуть, чуть улышается, если нет, я бы, можно ей, вытечить два сценария обозначить?
FANATIC Agency: Вот, что, ну. То что иначе, если, мы, Сейчас гарантирован ее устраиваем но мы, гарантированно мы скорее, всего, и так, можем попасть в задержку?
O!Sapiens Expert: Я бы не торопился?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тут есть еще два человека, который не получает денег. Эти два человека. На этом звонке?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, я думаю, что если выбирать?
Антон Аверьянов: Давайте но, может, быть правда, поговорим, что, закрываем диане там как, раз будет но, октябрь. Ноябрь и.
Антон Аверьянов: Все, что мы можем делать свой стороны это, привлечь новую клиентов постараться ускорить и?
Антон Аверьянов: Дожать тех, что кто сейчас. В барунке, на?
Антон Аверьянов: Воронки?
Антон Аверьянов: Это все, что я могу мне делать?
Антон Аверьянов: Независимости от по Футболу. Диана. Ты, Пожалуйста?
FANATIC Agency: Ну Типа негативный сценарий, это. Сначала Следующего Года условно там с. Января Позитивный, Сценарий это либо ноябрь, и либо декабрь. Вот так?
O!Sapiens Expert: Новона Ди Каприселился. Все, Же?
FANATIC Agency: Ну либо, декабрь. Да. Позитивный. Но, точно, можно вот так тогда. Сказать.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
FANATIC Agency: А кто, будет с ней тогда, вообще про это говорить и, В какой момент мы этот разговор делаем?
Антон Аверьянов: Очень Я поговорю?
Arina Mokrousova: В это логично может, быть должен, на этом созвоне говорить где, вот. Мы. Будем обменивать с, каким то впечатлениями?
Антон Аверьянов: Топ?
FANATIC Agency: Мне тоже. Можно Все вместе.
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да, я, так, я так. Я так и думал, да? Что. Ну. Проговорить что?
Arina Mokrousova: Лип?
Антон Аверьянов: Все окей. Все, Здорово по! Включенности по проектам а. Ты. Со своей стороны, все обязательства выполняешь, поговорим о наших обязательствах ну или?
Антон Аверьянов: Часы в программ. Чуть не словятся?
Arina Mokrousova: Женя. А можешь тогда написать? Вот эти варианты. Которые вы проговорили.
FANATIC Agency: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Я просто не запомнял. Надо, чтобы они были.
O!Sapiens Expert: Аню, должны, по идеи в транскрипе. Быть?
FANATIC Agency: Я напишу аренду чечета. Мне. Вообще. Не сложно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей. Окей?
Arina Mokrousova: Спасива. Большое?
FANATIC Agency: Транскрипт для Влады?
Arina Mokrousova: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Смотреть, технологии, эти. Конечно Удоверяю?
Arina Mokrousova: Старинки, а старинки, Женина, голова?
FANATIC Agency: Ручка. И блокнотик?
FANATIC Agency: Моя голова мое Богатство так. Ладно. Лолы. Решили.
O!Sapiens Expert: Наше?
FANATIC Agency: Остался вопрос ответственно чем, и делаем?
FANATIC Agency: Господи, Боже, с новым человеком?
Arina Mokrousova: Сно вообще. Да, вот Мы сейчас. Деньги обсуждали?
Arina Mokrousova: С одной стороны вроде, бы как, нет смысла никакого обсуждать, выходкого то нового, с другой, стороны надо понять какие, у нас, намерения?
Arina Mokrousova: Поиск дела. Не быстрое. Надо Ли вообще начинать для? Того чтобы?
Arina Mokrousova: Не знаю кого, то Иметь в виду где, нибудь, там не знаю в конце. Года. Года. Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Если все таки начинать, то?
Arina Mokrousova: Кого? Что это за человек? С какими компетенциями? На какую роль там, на какой? Продукт Ну, от, ной то уже второй вопрос. Первый. Скорее. Надо. Ли Сейчас кого то собесеть?
Arina Mokrousova: Кому то ручкой помахаю сказать Приветках дела, все, ли. У тебя хорошо на текущем, месте, и всякое такое?
FANATIC Agency: Давайте. Я Сейчас вам примерно обозначу загрузку которая, может у нас быть на сентябрь слэш. Октябрь, Я, вот, сейчас. Открыла табличку чтобы ее посмотреть?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: А у нас будет пионер. И нейминг. Это. Катен Проект И. Там, Как Бы супервизирование загрузка. Не Такая сильная?
FANATIC Agency: Очень надемся, что вернется все таки в кусвилл но Есть, ощущения что это будет не раньше?
FANATIC Agency: Этого. Какое нибудь конца сентября и, мне, кажется, вкусвел это, тот проект который уже, никому, нет смысла передавать это история. Которая. Арин и антон?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, Да, С?
FANATIC Agency: Придется вам затаскивать, потому что новый человек и туда включать это?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, Да, нас.
FANATIC Agency: Бесперспективно. У Нас сто процентов закончится отдать телу портал и, фьюче проф?
FANATIC Agency: И вряд ли только, только если на портал я рассчитываю что, там есть, история на. Какое, то дополнительное продолжение то что, помните, мы там говорили Про эйчар брэнд?
FANATIC Agency: Про какую то там про ечар бренд, мы. Говорили. И про, что, то еще я не. Помню мне в записах. Сохранилась, но это сильно под вопросом?
FANATIC Agency: То есть пионеры, Вкусвелл Пока примерно?
FANATIC Agency: А далее, вероятнее, всего, т, банк, и, их, следующий дайджест?
FANATIC Agency: Вот, но мне кажется с, ним?
FANATIC Agency: В теории алисы И даша могут справиться под супервизированием кати.
FANATIC Agency: Если мы. Сейчас набьем руку, у нас, вся фактура есть нам, нужно просто доискивать?
FANATIC Agency: По прежнему остается. Магнит это. Проект Лолы?
FANATIC Agency: С загрузкой. Вот такой?
FANATIC Agency: Нова Косметикс?
FANATIC Agency: Азбука вкуса, возможна воркшоп?
FANATIC Agency: И обес, но обес, скорее всего закончится. В конце сентября. Ну. Нет, не, в. Конце сентября скорее. Все, первые, две недели октября?
FANATIC Agency: Вот еще раз. Пионер Вкусвилл?
FANATIC Agency: Т. Банк?
FANATIC Agency: Магнит?
FANATIC Agency: Азбука, два, косметик?
Arina Mokrousova: Выгляде. Так. Что вот эти следующие два месяца мы. Справляемся таким состам?
Arina Mokrousova: Вопрос когда в том?
Arina Mokrousova: Надо Ли нам усиливаться?
Arina Mokrousova: И думать о ком то?
Arina Mokrousova: В будущих периодах. Вот, например, если встанет?
Arina Mokrousova: Полюс?
FANATIC Agency: Да, если ты банк в номер?
Arina Mokrousova: Или какой нибудь?
Arina Mokrousova: Тэ Банк Со своим?
Arina Mokrousova: И ассистентом?
Антон Аверьянов: Любов с первого место давай. Может, орем, просто. Походим посмотрим, ключо, Делает.
Антон Аверьянов: Баб?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот, Я у тебя хотела спросить?
Антон Аверьянов: Талант?
Arina Mokrousova: У меня, есть несколько, человек, но я тут, знаешь, как отак Подумала что, они вроде есть но, они кому то не подходят?
Arina Mokrousova: Если мы говорим про вот, эти новые какие то, роли?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот ось мы, вчера с лола например, тоже немножко говорили про?
Arina Mokrousova: Ее подружку стратега которая сейчас, был, у, даше горосковая работает?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Габарита Она. Классная она, Очень сильно шарит за архитектуру. Бренда вот За Вот это все но во сейчас, она работает ближе как, раз к концу каскада то есть, с креативом, с коммуникациями ну даже больше таких. Задач, и, вот ну как бы звать. Ее. К нам, Учитывая наше желание разворачиваться наоборот, как бы?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да?
Arina Mokrousova: По высоте. Подниматься в этом каскаде вертикально интегрироваться, вот наверх. И тех, ну типа нелогично то, есть, спец, хороший, классный?
Arina Mokrousova: Но как бы, и она к нам не пойдет, потому что нас нет, под этой задач. И она. Нам, по большому счету. Не нужна как. Много?
Arina Mokrousova: Потом. Вот сегодня, мы, сейчас, после хэц Прямо сразу с женю идем знакомиться там левченка, написал мы Просто Решили, она. Написала. И Мы такие да блим Пойдем Познакомимся у нее там пять. Лет. Опыта она, который трендвочинг, делает стратегом работала с они немножко работала, сет, расработал. Просто тебе познакомиться?
Arina Mokrousova: Но это такое вообще просто узнать человека. А вот кто нужен по типа, жу?
Arina Mokrousova: Мы тот жени подумали, что, если у нас есть слона там катя, которая, двигается вот к этому рнди?
Arina Mokrousova: Лоло, Которая, как, раз на таких проектах хочет, работать типа айбиэс?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот, но они все одно будутся вмещать. Это все одно трек. Это долгая история перехода и, мы не можем гарантировать сейчас словно, качества она. Никогда не будет больше заниматься Вот. Что, там проектами то. Есть напря, эта, много косметика она, точно будет, делать там кит. Еще вещи Вот То есть у, нас как, бы есть часть продуктов?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. Есть. Дойная, корова наша, а. Есть, Вот эти новые вот. Под новой как, будто, у нас есть два стратега два. Специалист. Хороших сильных. Может, нам нужен какой то, вот. Типа бренд. Стратег. Классический Вот на. Эту. Нашу Дойную Корову?
Антон Аверьянов: Бан?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, типа, делать. В этотки условные? Проекты Азбуки вкусвилла, там, т, Банка, Магнита Вообщего, Такое. Че. То.
Arina Mokrousova: А может, быть, какой, то альтернативный еще? Сценарий есть, что?
Антон Аверьянов: Jakby.
Антон Аверьянов: Na klasyczne produkty.
Антон Аверьянов: Od rosyjskich.
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
Антон Аверьянов: Nie sklepu.
Антон Аверьянов: Pomocy.
Arina Mokrousova: Давай, можем просто же созваниваться и знакомиться с людьми ничего не обещаю. А просто говорят Что мы, Знакомимся вот?
Антон Аверьянов: Plany.
Антон Аверьянов: Bardzo.
Антон Аверьянов: Ciotka od smaku.
Arina Mokrousova: Ну Нет, да, я?
Arina Mokrousova: Я думаю, что это даже в приритете. Типа. Можно просто сейчас держать это в голове давай слово на. Следующей. Неделю встречу проведем а потом, там будем?
Антон Аверьянов: Bardzo.
Arina Mokrousova: Уже с тобой встречаться от?
Антон Аверьянов: Strategicznym Produktem.
Антон Аверьянов: To moje.
Антон Аверьянов: Бронториентированная стратегия Называется там где есть?
Антон Аверьянов: Не графики и движения стрелок в прабый верх. Это дейская это идеологическое оставляющее?
Антон Аверьянов: Вот, И может быть, нам, общество. Смотреть людини из агентств игра стратегов а, людей, которые, были на, позиции какого нибудь съемо, в каком нибудь яндексе а Потому, что ему там, ожидание козелкими платят?
Антон Аверьянов: Новопостолванная Ваня с милянским Тестала Живе столько. Раз, если что, то, для, него?
Arina Mokrousova: Не сигайся он желавита Вышел?
Arina Mokrousova: Джон.
Антон Аверьянов: Он. Когда, вышел?
Arina Mokrousova: Не знаю вот. Мне Кажется, недавно мы разговаривали?
Антон Аверьянов: Видео нашел, потому что я?
Антон Аверьянов: Буквально. Сто. Пять тысяча. Восемьсот восемнадцатого, года?
Arina Mokrousova: Нену ваня. Смелянский. Безусловно. Это классный спец но, Насколько, мы можем его типа, ну, взять, к, Себе, в команду где У нас есть Катя, лова. И Ваня Смелянский Ну типа?
O!Sapiens Expert: Нет. Там, даже по деньгам?
Arina Mokrousova: Салют?
Arina Mokrousova: По деньгам по конфигурациям. Ну. Типа?
Антон Аверьянов: Коня?
Антон Аверьянов: Но Он не ну смотрен он кирилл который. Был брандиректором. Борга. Потом Семпла?
Антон Аверьянов: Вышел в это агентство отца и геро что то, там?
Антон Аверьянов: Ай, Пай, Тайгер Форс Тайгер. Из ошиб?
Arina Mokrousova: Но Он наверно, сам вышел услова на, Какую то позицию ли да, то есть, какую то, мою, позицию типа приглажать, его просто обычно с петтом работать. Мне тоже. Странно человек с таким опытом?
Антон Аверьянов: План. Давай, Ты, на каком, трапить себе найду еще раз? Буду? Ехать С Чата этих где их ел написал Мне, просто надо просто сидеть и перебирать чата я не. Помню как людей зовут а находите?
Arina Mokrousova: А вот это алина Которая, из макинди?
Arina Mokrousova: На которой на бис другого дана.
Антон Аверьянов: Она вообще, друговая?
Антон Аверьянов: Она другого, Она другого формата, одна, скорее, выпадате новые. Продукты она ну. Как Бы?
FANATIC Agency: Что, ж, про него подумала?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
Антон Аверьянов: Она из девочка из амфуты По Математике и по физике?
Arina Mokrousova: Да ну, как, бы слушай я тоже с физмата как, бы можно я. Имею веду что, можно, что у, нее есть интересня, то у нее интерес?
Антон Аверьянов: Смит?
Антон Аверьянов: Если никогда, не?
Антон Аверьянов: Не говорил на эту тему Можно просто помолтать и, у. Нее есть. Большой интерес к темне будущего?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
Антон Аверьянов: Мизионерству. Мы Ее Подключили?
Arina Mokrousova: Но она короче, катя, скорее да вы. Оренди. Лабораторию?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да, да, да, да, да, мы, с сашей, тиндиковым?
Антон Аверьянов: Это профессор, построеться делов отключали, ее, когда то?
Антон Аверьянов: Года. Полтора. Назад на еще училась?
Антон Аверьянов: Поискать. Она помогала классификацию бизионеров сделать, ее то написала сообщение что это, вообще был одной из самых интересных задач который у меня она в жизни занималась?
Антон Аверьянов: Мы, никуда ее, не, продвили она, выпутались, понять, такие, вообще везения добывают вокруг чего она, строят, лиж, и, так далее, я могу попробовать? С Пниров поискателем. Чудо! Осталось?
Антон Аверьянов: Вот и вот такими штуками нравится заниматься ростом не знаю насколько. Она может, прям?
Антон Аверьянов: Творческие придумать что, это нибудь?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, ладно?
Arina Mokrousova: Хорошо, Короче, Ну, Давай договоримся, что, это задача там Третьего Периоритета сейчас нам. Нужно. С дианой решить потом слово и встречиться?
Arina Mokrousova: Поговорить про итоги испытательного поговорить про этот момент занятым. Трудоустройством штат. А после того, как мы вот с ней поговорим мы там начнем думать про?
Arina Mokrousova: То, чтобы просто встречаться, с кем то, знакомиться, и. Вообще?
Arina Mokrousova: Узнавать, кто сейчас на рынке?
Arina Mokrousova: Есть?
FANATIC Agency: Ну, Как, Акварик, у. Нас. Всегда, есть возможность кого то поцепить пока на, фрил на Какие То Проекты?
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
FANATIC Agency: Вот.
FANATIC Agency: В любом случае, мне кажется, можно найти но, здесь это такая как, бы история?
FANATIC Agency: Наколхозять, на Какое то время плюс еще не стоит наверно. Забывать что, ну, вряд, ли конечно даша захочет. Уйти, Из фанатик Она. Вот у нее как был уровень лояльности Очень Высокий она. Прям. Реально любит вот ну как бы команду, и вот все. Что. Здесь происходит?
Arina Mokrousova: Но еще, это направление маркетинга Любит?
O!Sapiens Expert: Не сможет сопоставлять свою фултайм работу долгой. Срок?
FANATIC Agency: Да?
FANATIC Agency: Да, да, вот как бы, здесь, такой как бы может быть шанс но, просто она говорит что, то чем, она сейчас. Там занимается. Это вообще абсолютно ее?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. Как, бы демотивирует и, все такое то есть на. Фанатике наоборот, находит, хоть какую то душно то, что, там у нет перформанс вообще. Аналитика а?
FANATIC Agency: Игровая индустрия. И вот этот вот, все, то, от чего, ее вообще как, бы, тошнит о винчик антон?
FANATIC Agency: Какой хороший вид?
Антон Аверьянов: К завершению дня?
Антон Аверьянов: Выведи Ли вашей дядьку с, которым я шестался?
FANATIC Agency: Нет. Анна. Маньяк И похож?
Arina Mokrousova: Нет?
FANATIC Agency: Как его зовут?
Антон Аверьянов: Скажи. Мне ка?
Антон Аверьянов: Александр Савельев Александр, Васильевич Савельев?
Arina Mokrousova: Откуда это? Что за компания?
Антон Аверьянов: Канал. Санкт Петербург?
Антон Аверьянов: Это села. Да, Бангс написано, А Ты куришь путь?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, я. Почему задумала что у тебя относится типо вечером?
Антон Аверьянов: Нет. Ну. Вечером. Про то что это, куришь путина какой То, Путин, был акционером Этого банка идемо?
FANATIC Agency: Епа?
Антон Аверьянов: Брайан Семидесяти?
FANATIC Agency: Райм. Девяностых на карте?
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
FANATIC Agency: Нудь, пофоткам?
FANATIC Agency: Блин?
Антон Аверьянов: Поэтому я от в раздумье, до на вернусь, или, там во, время?
FANATIC Agency: Увлекажитесь. Ты. Придешь с легким амбрел он тебя за Своего Примет Скажешь Ну?
FANATIC Agency: Да, уж, конечно, не знаю но?
FANATIC Agency: Удачи?
FANATIC Agency: Мы, как будто все обсудили у. Нас Еще осталось десять минут. На. Какую, то не, знаю там рефлексивный рефлексию, или, что то такое Если че то хочется еще обсудить к нам пришел. Т, вчера, наконец. Таки. С, тендером?
FANATIC Agency: На разработку, позиционирования и и ассистента. Вот есть же мысли как, ими, сделаете презентацию там дедлайн. Прям рядом с. Полисом у полиса, двадцать шестого у, т, двадцать Седьмого. Очень радует, конечно не Сдохнуть, бы?
Антон Аверьянов: Это на Кп Дедлайн. Если Работ узнать?
FANATIC Agency: Нет, это на Кп. Слава. Богу Но, Хотя бы здесь понятно блять собирать презентацию а, с, полюсом, нику, я не понятно.
FANATIC Agency: Вот.
FANATIC Agency: Ладно.
Антон Аверьянов: Выговорились?
FANATIC Agency: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: А рефлексию, тот по поводу, чего, хотела по поводу вообще всего что, происходит?
FANATIC Agency: Ну Мало, Ли, то раз мы, можем и не рефлексировать можем разойтись как бы, мне то че?
Arina Mokrousova: То еще тебя. Нет. Рефлексии?
FANATIC Agency: У меня.
Arina Mokrousova: Да?
Антон Аверьянов: Рефлексия дела, сукупы индивидуально.
Arina Mokrousova: Ладно.
Arina Mokrousova: Не буду тогда вам ничего говорить пока?
FANATIC Agency: Почему? Почему?
Антон Аверьянов: Отчет. Ну. А, что там что, там?
O!Sapiens Expert: Пока?
FANATIC Agency: Заинтригуй у вас. Буду нище говорить да.
Антон Аверьянов: Заинтриговала?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, не у меня нечего сказать я. Просто Чучу просто я, продолжаю.
O!Sapiens Expert: Пока?
Антон Аверьянов: Пока?
Arina Mokrousova: Давайте Пока?
Антон Аверьянов: Федор. За посилавку показывай.